Speaker 1: All right.
Let's hit a couple of other things here as
we continue with today's show, we continue
to wonder about what the 2024 presidential
election is going to look like.
And a big part of that is is Joe Biden going
to run for reelection?
We don't have an answer to that question.
Yet another part of it is is Donald Trump
going to run for the Republican primary?
And we don't have an answer to that yet, either.
There is a new poll out which says that as
of right now, that's basically a dead heat
race Biden versus Trump.
If that were to be it, I believe it was about
45 for each a tie, statistically a tie within
the margin of error.
And we can, of course, raise questions about
how valuable is a poll.
I guess we are two years and nine months,
so 24, 33 months from that election.
It's probably not particularly valuable other
than to tell us that as of right now, there
is still great appetite from tens of millions
of people in this country for Donald Trump
to be president again.
As I've said before, I believe that a big
factor in whether Trump will or won't run
again is Trump's health in 2023 and 2024.
He's not a particularly healthy guy.
He's not a particularly young guy.
And it's a statistical reality that his health
in 2024 may not lend itself to a presidential
campaign.
I don't know, and I'm not wishing him harm.
I'm just saying it's aside from the will he
believe he can win.
Will he be distracted with something else?
Whatever the health issue is, is a real question,
and I'm not saying it's not a real question
for Joe Biden, either.
That being said, we are starting to see signs
of interest from Donald Trump in running in
2024.
One of those signs of interest is that almost
at the turn of the new year, Trump has already
restarted rallies, doing a rally in Florence,
Arizona, on January 15th.
He'll be doing a rally in Conroe, Texas, where
we will have a correspondent, by the way,
this Saturday, January 29.
So he seems very interested in being involved
in continuing to be sort of a kingmaker in
the context of the midterms in order to then
justify running in 2024.
Here's another just little hint this is Donald
Trump golfing, which he does a lot now, and
some kind of sycophant who's filming him teeing
off refers to him as the 45th president of
the United States and then Donald Trump, says
the 45th and the 47th.
Just another little sign that indeed, he may
be planning on running.
Take a look.
Speaker 3: Oh, you're so lucky to likely to
be
Speaker 5: one of those lucky.
We'll be lucky if we're up first on TV.
46th President of the United States, 45th
and 47th first.
Yes, I love Mr. Trump.
Speaker 3: Oh gentlemen,
Speaker 1: I'm sure everybody tells him how
great his tee shot is, right?
No matter how good it is.
Speaker 5: Say you're beautiful.
Easy game.
I think it's pretty boring to be middle all
the time.
You want to keep it low when shrunk.
Speaker 1: Yes, exactly.
All right.
So, you know, I don't know how much we need
to or should read into that.
But needless to say, it's just another little
sign, another small indicator that indeed,
Donald Trump may, may be planning to run in
2024.
And the scariest part is, as of right now,
if the election were held today, he might
actually win